for over a year we've been talking about
how Amazon were planning a Stargate
straight to cinema movie so why on Earth
would they now be considering changing
that plan welcome to SRE your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie
[Music]
Channel so first and exclusively I
dropped the news last week that Amon is
seriously considering switching from a
movie to a TV series now I've been able
to get a few more sources telling me
actually that yeah this is a serious
possibility that even though there's
been significant work done on the
straight to cinema movie they were
planning they're not at a stage where
they couldn't just switch to a series if
they wanted to I'm actually being told
that what they will basically do is
rework the movie that they had planned
and redo as a 2hour opener for the new
season that actually this project was
always supposed to be part of a bigger
franchise anyway it's not going to be
Standalone so it's actually not that
difficult for them to do
this now I am also told that the
decision was made last week but we don't
know what the decision was they seem to
be holding their cards quite closely to
their chest at the moment possibly
because two days after their meeting I
dropped a video telling you about it so
I apologize about that but why on Earth
would they be thinking about switching
and actually what financial reasons
would they have for it right in the
video where I dropped this news we
talked about the strikes we talked about
how it's given Amazon time to actually
reconsider their options for lots of
projects it's given them time to
actually look at what the fans want it's
given them time to look at met data Etc
Hollywood though is also now a bit
different there is a different financial
situation
and a confidence problem so what you
have to basically understand is that all
of these decisions about movies TV
series
Etc are made by people it's very similar
to sort of how the stock market works
you have to remember again that prices
go up and down in the stock market and
it's about confidence if the stock
market loses confidence in a business
the price goes down and the company can
go out of business in Hollywood it's a
little bit similar a project gets either
green lit or scrapped based on how
confident the bosses are in their
decision and it would seem that the
confidence in Stargate has shifted
slightly now I don't think it's
necessarily decreased I actually just
think that they've realized that because
Cinema is different that perhaps the
Stargate movie wouldn't
fit actually putting it into the cinema
would be a big risk now franchises in
general and we discussed this in the
previous video are doing badly Marvel
Indiana Jones DC Mission Impossible and
so on and so on people seem to have
turned off to the franchise or at very
least they don't go to the cinema to
watch it because again our viewing
habits have changed and we tend to like
to watch things on the streaming service
that we're paying for every month so
when a big Disney movie comes out why
would you go to the cinema I've got
Disney plus and it'll be on there in a
couple of months the viewing habits have
changed so I get the sense that there's
a feeling from certain people and
certain insiders have basically sh
shared this with me to say they think
over Amazon that a project like Stargate
won't get a decent box office because
people will assume it'll be on Amazon
Prime in a couple of months I'll watch
it then and even if they have to pay for
it at home it's a damsite cheaper than
getting a bunch of cinema tickets to go
it's like what2 pound or $20 a Cinema
ticket or you can watch it on early
release at home for the price of one
ticket all of you the entire family so
it's a no-brainer Amazon seem to have
realized this and are now may be
thinking that they either need to do a
straight to Amazon Prime movie which
apparently is still on the cards or they
just do the series a series that 93% of
1,300 voters on my channel say they want
we don't necessarily want a two-hour
movie that's going to cost hundred
million we want 10 hours 20 hours 30
hours of a series now don't get me wrong
I would have loved to have seen star to
the cinema and I kind of hope they still
go that way because I think it would be
amazing but if their confidence has
shifted they have a choice to make they
can spend what we were being told was
around 70 to 80 million on a movie which
actually then costs probably 30 or $40
million more again to advertise and
Market $1 120 $130 million
conservatively or they can spend what
I'm being told is roughly about $50
million on 10 hours of Television which
they then basically don't have to spend
any money marketing or at least very
little because Amazon is basically One
Big Marketing machine they really
wouldn't have to do much to get the word
out because channels like CRA will do it
for them so that's the choice they have
to make 120 $130 million on a movie that
they're not sure will make the money
back or much less on a series they are
confident will drive viewing
figures so what would you do now for me
to be honest this is a no-brainer the
fans us skaters overwhelmingly want them
to do a series it makes sense from a
development point of view because it's
been off your screens for 15 years and
if you are doing a continuation and
we've always been told that we're going
to do a
continuation then two hours isn't enough
time for you to fill in any gaps it
would have to be a standal low movie and
I'm being told it's not so the only way
for me to do this is to do a series of
Television where you have the
opportunity and you have the time to
fill in a lot of the gaps that's
happened over the last 15 years and to
World
build that is why I think it only makes
sense to do a series and the people at
the top Amazon and MGM they're not
stupid I actually think also there's a
slight truth to something I was told by
another Insider that has actually just
said that actually Amazon might not have
quite realized what they had on their
hands with Stargate it is trended on
Twitter or X whatever the hell is called
this week every other week for the last
two years that I've been following it we
get really good views on our Channel
gate World dial the gate etc etc still
get great views on any Stargate video
they do there is an
constant voracious appetite from Gator
for more information and more news and
for more
Stargate I actually think Amazon were
Keen to do Stargate before because they
saw the viewing figures from reruns of
sg1 SGU and G but they never quite
appreciated how much the fans wanted
this and now hopefully if they have done
and The Insider that I've Miss speakon
to says they might have done they've
realized that actually they need to get
this right and the best way to get this
right is with a thoughtful planned
franchise a series to begin with
potentially then a Prime movie that
would be the culmination of maybe two or
three seasons coming together and then
maybe in the future when Cinema is a
little bit more
predictable maybe then Stargate returns
to the
cinema I actually wonder what the future
for Cinema even is and I really hope
that whatever decision Amazon go with
they have the balls to follow through
and they have the confidence in what is
my favorite TV show ever get in Brad
right make a show that makes sense and
then hopefully one day we can return to
the cinema but that is why we think they
are maybe
reconsidering because of money because
of confidence in the market and because
of the changing World we're currently
living
in but guys get into the comments and
tell me what you think are you one of
the 93% or would you have actually loved
to have sin Stargate at the cinema in a
way I was really excited about this
because the confidence Amazon was
showing in the franchise doing a
cinematic
movie it's quite staggering Star Trek
can't get a cinematic movie but Stargate
could I quite like that and hey they
still might do it or are you on the
93% of people that's saying No thank you
very much I want 10 hours 20 hours 30
hours of television I don't need a
cinematic movie just
yet I'm actually leaning in the greedy
area if I want both eventually but we'd
get a series on our screens quicker and
it makes more sense to do that first
because you get the World building so
I'm in the 93% gives a serious first but
what do you think get to the comments if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to
patreon.com most of our new videos
appear first and you get to see them
without the adverts you lucky bunnies
for just a small contribution each month
that really supports the channel and you
even get a free gift after three months
can't say fair than that also and
finally go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you to digest as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next
time
[Music]